die diesel besitzer baden jetzt aus dass
unsere bundesregierung seit jahren
nichts macht in dieser angelegenheit die
fahrverbote kommen noch nicht
überraschen freunde die grenzwerte ja es
ist so eine scheiße überraschung die die
grenzwerte wurden vor fast 19 jahren
festgelegt überlegen sie mal das heißt
ein kind das so alt ist wie diese
grenzwerte darf heute schon mit seinem
diesel die stadt vollmöller
wichtig ist dass man die sache jetzt
bitte nicht runter spielt es geht um
einzelne städte in denen muss noch mehr
gehandelt werden aber es geht wirklich
nicht um die gesamte fläche
nein wenn man das sind eine handvoll
kleinstädte wie stuttgart düsseldorf
hamburg köln frankfurt berlin halle
münchen
insgesamt komme ich gerade mal auf 66
kommunen freunde meine viel groß ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass da einer wohnt
jetzt mal ehrlich
die autoindustrie weigert sich standhaft
nachrüstungen zu bezahlen hat über
nachrüstungen
man kann sie leider nicht zwingen weil
es sind sehr sensible menschen deswegen
wahrscheinlich fahrverbote zum beispiel
in stuttgart oder wie herr der ringe
fans nennen smogs einem ende kommen wir
lachen aber das ist bitter für die
betroffenen deren wagen sind jetzt
nichts mehr wert demnächst hier
tröstende worte vom zuständigen
verkehrsminister und dann kann man nur
sagen schaut euch um wohl gibt es
möglichkeiten nachzurüsten lohnt sich
die nachrüstung wenn nicht dann dann
kaufen sie ein elektrisches auto oder
ein plug-in nicht geben
kauft euch doch ein neues auto warum
muss man euch denn alles erklären liebe
mitbürger ja nur noch chaos und
verunsicherung soll jetzt wirklich jede
stadt selber fahrverbote durchsetzen mit
hunderttausenden neuen schildern wir
müssen die aussehen ist doch wahnsinn
wahnsinn nur unsicherheit welche autos
sind in zukunft überhaupt noch sicher
erlaubt meine klar ganz safe ist man
immer mit car to go kennen sie das ist
eine weitgehend emissionsfreie
technologie kam sauberer geht's
sauberer geht
denn so
immer und völlig absurd ist ja wem jetzt
von verschiedenen seiten die schuld
gegeben wird an dem diesel desaster
hier kommt mein persönliches
lieblingsargument das heutige urteil ist
ein schlag gegen freiheit und eigentum
weil wir uns zu gefangenen
menschengemachter grenzwerte machen ja
menschengemachte grenzwerte kurze
nachfrage
wer soll denn sonst die grenzwerte
machen schimpansen
wer am besten die affen aus diesem vw
folter labor das wäre eine gute idee
linda wird nur noch getoppt von dieser
bescheuerten afd aktion ich bin stolzer
dieselfahrer ja über lesen wir die große
law and order partei fdp die sonst immer
rechtsbruch schreit die idee für euren
nächsten aufkleber ich fahre in den
deutschen grenzwerten von 1934